how long have you been drinking again
life's short it's okay to have some
[Music]
fun according to a sheriff's office in
Florida the TLC star turned herself in
on a warrant reportedly issued for drunk
driving the police department couldn't
share any more details about the
original warrant because it was from
outside their agency
ET has reached out to Kim's reps and TLC
the network behind her family show for
comment I'm not doing a shot oh no
the arrest comes just months after Kim's
decision to start drinking alcohol
hey cheers to our first drink together
something her husband Barry didn't
support Barry is pretty firmly you know
anti-alcohol of any kind except for
kombucha being his wife all of these
years I just kind of supported that and
went along with everything that he said
I don't think he really knows that I you
know am having an occasional drink here
and there more than alcohol came between
the couple there's something going on in
our relationship that
is not good but I don't fully understand
what's going on in June Kim and Barry
announced they were separating after 24
years of marriage so your mother and I
are separating
the trajectory looks to be
you know divorce at the time they told
E.T quote while this was not an easy
decision we know it's the best choice
for both of us
the former couple has nine kids together
and plan to co-parent our amazing
children as they navigate this new
chapter in our lives we're gonna make
sure that your lives change as little as
possible and dad and I will always be
friends
[Music]